hi I'm I'm moma um you can find me on
social media on ebay on twitter um I
work at least at the back in software
engineer I think we're hiring like crazy
so if you're like interested in job you
can contact me I've been Python
developer for about seven years I've
started working on pi PI for about four
years um I started as a google Summer of
Code student so I wrote um sie some
Satan backend for pi pi which didn't
really work on as a lot of google Summer
Food Project and yeah i'm i'm very
interested in bringing more libraries to
bye-bye i think that's one of them like
pitfalls of pi PI so I've worked also
non pi pi which is our own
implementation of numpy Gnawa and I'm
currently working on climate our biases
which is um a project I'm going to show
in this talk so my big problem with
python is that our implementation like
our main implementation isn't that great
so how can we get better implementations
and while without changing a language
because that's the language we love and
use so yeah right now what was the
problem with um the current state of
affairs so C Python is like ninety-eight
percent of all Python like installations
around but it has like poor performance
and it has the infamous gear on pi PI is
like much less use it's like probably
like linux on the desktop kind of market
share it has much much better
performance and by by ASTM is go is
showing like very very good progress and
so that's how we can potentially remove
the
um and like jython ironpython and
everything else like according to buy p
I starts at least they are like
virtually unused on quite a few people
like just use jython for like
orchestrating like java stuff and stuff
so they don't choose by p IE but like in
terms of pi PI stats they are irrelevant
um and yes in terms of like the general
like language situation so go has
appeared on it's pretty fast um and it's
great at currency it has no Gil and it
has very good construct for building
concurrent systems on javascript is
where the competition in JavaScript EMS
is really heavy so a lot of competition
then it's really really fast on PHP
while Facebook runs on PHP so they work
on optimizing PHP quite a lot um yeah
and while we're still so that's kind of
disappointing and languages like Julie
hours or like created because of the
deficient deficiencies of Python so um
yes in term of six tensions it's pretty
hard to switch between implementations
because well almost everyone uses
especially in like PI data like
ninety-five percent of people use numpy
which is a sink station so like you
can't switch to see extension like to UM
alternative implementations if you have
a bunch of six tensions six tensions
while numpy is useful right but C Python
don't change much because the sea the
sea extension API is really like tie to
implementation details so for example
you you really can't remove the Gale
from
from C Python because of that bye-bye
well pie pie gets a lot better every day
we reflect a lot of stuff improve a lot
of stuff but at the same time the
extension two bodies well it's what it
is so yes if you see like if you look at
on the Python implementation market
basically see python is like keeping its
user captive right you're you're using
the extensions and then your code
depends on it and then you're stuck and
I think like much more complete
competition will be very beneficial like
even like I walk and popeyes i'm a bit
biased but like is something much better
than pipe i like came out i think that
would be like awesome for the community
um yes so like why you don't just
doesn't just the pipe a team build like
a capi implementation and be done with
it so even if we did like stuff like
siphon use much more than the regular
like official capi seitan likes to look
inside there like structures and and
stuff so like that's virtually
impossible to implement and well if you
do implement the official APA it makes a
lot of assumptions so and a lot of
assumptions on things that affect
performance so if you if you implement
the capi you end up with something
that's pretty close to C Python
including in top of performance in gear
on for example yes reference counting um
that's pretty slow and for removing the
gale it makes removing the get
impossible so yeah if we if you use the
capi then no performance and no
concurrency in pure python that list
so on how other languages solve that
problem there are like two families of
capi in general um jni and VA choose one
kind of API that handles like references
much nicely it's closer to to the capi
than the lower Julia family which uses
like virtual tag basically um if you
have written blue algeria code then what
it would sound familiar but like this
the api's are basically just as
performant and as useful as the capi and
they don't have the same deficiencies so
can you have something similar to those
API is while we can hear it's not like
that much work it's mostly like
political work rather than technical
work so we the pipe I team have
implemented well have written something
called cff I which is on which stands
for c function fine function interface
it works on pi PI in C Python and you
could use that to build a new API yeah
it's a lot of political work and trying
to convince everybody and then like you
still have num buying stuff in people
are object are not gonna like rewrite
numpy from scratch in anytime soon so
yeah that's what you would need to keep
the current API in the new API for a
while so that people i can start
incrementally pop that stuff so what
does pipe i fit in this right so
implementations of deficiencies um so
how does pipe i fit in this and fixes
those efficiencies so first of all it's
it's very flexible by page has of is
very like it's built in a python which
is a language that allows us to
basically like swap anything we want if
we want something more efficient we can
like very
very quickly change change like how
things work and it's also built with a
jit inside which stands for just-in-time
compiler you can check on speed dot x
right at all we have a bunch of
benchmark that we run on every night on
um like nightly build our own fate seven
times faster than C Python which doesn't
mean anything because well each program
is unique so you might get like 1.2
times faster or like 1,000 times faster
um it competes with like JavaScript
implementations and stuff like that and
then the concept behind the GT that you
pay the cost of what you use which means
that for example in Python on integers
are objects which makes it um slow but
you should don't choose them as objects
and they are just choose adjusting like
implemented as regular integers which
are as fast as well like see like
languages so yes I have a demo um if the
demo gods are nice it will work so let's
say I have this video of me skiing it's
not me anyway and I want to run um edge
detection on it so I wrote something in
pure python like it doesn't choose numpy
it doesn't choose anything just plain
Python and let's see how how it works
don't look at the negative HPS that
doesn't work well now it works yes after
three friends it works so well if I want
to run like on a single image it would
probably be quite decent try but like
that's no onion like real time
so let's run it with Piper
that's real time um and to prove that
it's not like it's really real time
that's really like it runs at 15fps but
that's because my webcam is too so it
runs out like if you remove the right
FPS limit it turns out like 250 FPS on
on on the example I shown before so yes
back to the demo so yes we're removing a
lot of course from like using lists for
example list on pipe i if they are like
just plain list of like integers or
floats they are basically like just see
a raise so that's what allows us to have
like very fast matham in pure python so
yes I talked a bit about cff I earlier
um so we all like to like interact with
C code pretty easily on a lot of
libraries are written in C on and yes
using them is very useful in using them
like having a very easy way of
interacting with them is very useful um
so cff I with you can call any c
function you want you can also expose
python functions so just like the capi
if you want to embed Python you can
using cff I um you can also like
implement part of your system in Python
and like have on another part in C and
have the C chord Python the callbacks
it's really really fast on pi PI we used
we used it to implement the pipe I
plugin in you whiskey which is a web
server and basically the load balancer
couldn't keep up with pi PI um and yes
you can do anything you can do with the
shape here you can do it with cff I
and yes we all hate the gill like the
gill is not nice it's evil so we work we
are working on something or pop ASTM
which stands for software transactional
memory you can look it up on Wikipedia
if you're interested more but basically
it's a way of dealing with threads
running in parallel but um without
having to care about locking and threads
and stuff like that like locks are even
more evil than the game so that's good
and you can tell it's not like
multiprocessing where you have to like
have your data completely separate
between workers you can have you can
share memory as much as you want of
course if you like work on the same
value all the time then it's not going
to be fast so what about like what can
we do now to improve the extension
support so I wrote a quick like hawkish
thing that like could end up bringing
like a lot of benefits basically it's
embedding C Python inside pi PI and then
you send while it's basically an RPC
system between PI by NC Python in the
same process so i have also demo um so
so this is bye bye can everybody see ok
so i roped my tool let's have um let's
important see extension so Matt plot
clip is one paparazzi extension um by
lab is pretty slow to import even on C
Python so um and let's stop plotting
stuff
oh yeah that's Matt Barkley burning on
pi PI
so yes to summarize like we can do a lot
better in term of implementations as
what we're doing right now um pai pai is
definitely working on like being the
best implementation around um but at the
same time having alternative
implementations that you can't use it
because you end up like with tons of six
tension that you can choose isn't like
it's not great so like we should work on
having an implementation independent
ecosystem um I think like it's quite a
bit of work but at the same time it's
very rewarding for the Python community
in my opinion so yeah thank you um you
can find me if you have questions Laurie
thank you very much for my questions I
think like it's film so i'm not sure i
can say much but arms big San Francisco
startups with like about that its logo
uses it like for some internet stuff on
some storage stuff like I'm not giving
you names but like yes the difference
it's like on how to say this
diplomatically so yes basically it's
built as a like a different family of
Josie Tom compilers on the creators of
person thinks it's better um I'm not
convinced like the last version shows
that it's one percent faster than C
Python which means zero so like but
they're working on compatibility or the
one performance so like wait and see I'm
not I don't think it's going to be like
a big player in there like last next few
years maybe one day it will be
you like the thing that would kill pipe
I don't know but I'm not convince so in
your edge detection down can you say
like which lines exactly contributing
speed oh like where where where was the
biggest well like it's written like you
would write it in C so like you just
iterate over a list of lists of integers
and you just do like double loop and um
do math on it so like it's a lot of like
either coast of iteration and math and
stuff like that like it's it's built
very nicely but it's performs really
really went on paper
um see ya um well seats the only stable
ABI around um like if everything talks
using C right if you want to talk to
Java you have to go through Jane I which
is C um if you want to call rust on the
wearer rust handles it is like you add
some like annotation and it ends up with
the see a bi um it's the same with
Haskell writing it doesn't yes it does
um in the like see left part like you
write C but it's really just like
definitions of like see ABI stuff so
like you can call anything you want you
can you can definitely call rust for
example or like anything that supports
the capi you can you can do it like in
the like verify part like you come you
can't really do it like it's see but in
the CAF bar like you can put like see
the capi definitions but like your
implementation can be of any language
any language to improvise see yes mm
okay any other questions is everything
to those with the disease you presently
like site in turn on the wall of the pie
or just unique um well it's alpha
software so like just missing missing
like types and stuff but you can pass
numpy arrays to any function you want
you can use like it's very like you
don't have to do anything like if it's
not implemented and like it's a beginner
or side but it's it's a very thin layer
that's like quite complete and yes you
could call potentially scikit-learn i
think i should do like something about
like having a proof of concept of
running scikit-learn but yes it's pretty
simple one more question great so start
doing that by using cff i just because
it's not nice running see extension
can I I've only tested on see but can I
just develop that and assume it's going
to work on my mind or other any other
considerations um on the like cff a
power no it's just plain it just plain e
works um there are some so pi pi e has
like delay garbage collection so like
you can end up with arm you have to be
careful that you explicitly free stuff
that could potentially be magically Fred
on CB icon as soon as possible so like
if you need like one instance of
something at any time like you have to
make sure that you explicitly free it
for example like that yes garbage
collection is you have to make sure of
that but like in terms of just cff icff
i just exactly the same way on bye bye
in sabatham thank you very much for